two nearly three decades on the force
NYPD precinct commander
his name is Richard Bray he just quit
he's over in the Bronx
the reason instead of supporting police
leaders police leaders are now placating
riders with measures like disbanding a
plainclothes anti-crime unit six hundred
strong police are also being held back
as fireworks attacks are ravaging the
city one of those who recent fireworks
attacks by the way injured a
three-year-old boy that says shone
yesterday's New York Post cover you seen
that bill de blasio has bigger concerns
though he's just announced he'll be
painting black lives matters on a street
outside Trump Tower Sepp Baron is an
editor at city journal he joins us now
hey Seth what about those priorities
from the mayor well the mayor's always
got his priorities straight Brian as you
well know
sure painting black lives matter in
front of Trump Tower
look things like that taking down
statues all of that's easy keeping
neighborhoods safe fixing the schools
that sort of thing is hard so you know
people like de Blasio are always gonna
take the easy way out and that's what
we've been saying someone should tell
someone should tell him that Donald
Trump doesn't work there now he's in
Washington
number two is Seth murders are up 48%
shootings are up 86 percent he disbanded
the anti-crime unit his bail laws make
it almost impossible to hold anyone in
jail his Commissioner is beside himself
keep precinct commanders are quitting
this is a crisis
he made yet this is all his doing the
the commander of the 46 precinct in the
Bronx Richard Bray he apparently just
had it I mean shootings in his in his
precinct are up 600 percent over last
year for the last 28 days there's been
dozens of shootings crime and with the
disbanding of the anti-crime unit I mean
those are the guys who
take guns off the street and now there's
no direction
apparently you know I've heard reports
that they wanted to have him go and take
a knee at the next precinct community
meeting and he was like I'm not doing it
this isn't the this isn't what I'm here
for
we're not we're not being allowed to do
our jobs the commissioner even has said
that the criminal justice system is
imploding in New York it's it's it's
really looking pretty bad Ryan when the
commissioner says that and he would have
control with that to a degree it's
getting scary and by the way the black
lives matter group just in case you want
to know what they're about the quote
from one of their leaders if the u.s.
doesn't give us what we want then we
will burn down the system and replace it
good continue to paint that in the
street what the heck is going on he
can't get out soon enough
Seth Barron thanks so much